cette semaine je vous propose une fois
n'est pas coutume de surligner non pas
un ou une politique mais un journal
enfin si on peut encore appeler ça un
journal je parle de france-soir célèbre
quotidien de l'ancien temps mais qui
depuis qu'il a basculé 100% en ligne a
fait un virage à 180 degrés sur la route
du journalisme et prend de plus en plus
ses distances avec les faits je veux
pour preuve un article publié samedi
dernier annonçant que la cour pénale
internationale a accepté une plainte
déposée par deux avocats
attaquant le gouvernement d'israël au
motif qu'il mènerait des expériences de
vaccination illégale contre le coc u19
sur ses citoyens israël on le sait mène
une campagne de vaccination tambour
battant avec le vaccin de pfizer et avec
à ce jour la moitié de sa population qui
est vacciné contre la bête à picot la
cpi aurait-elle donc reconnu que la
plainte pour expérience illégale sur
tout un peuple seraient fondées et bien
cette annonce de françois est totalement
fausse en réalité la plainte des deux
avocats qui est la seule chose qui
existe vraiment dans cette histoire a
seulement été réceptionné par le bureau
du procureur de la cpi qui en a accusé
réception
il s'agit de la procédure normale
lorsque la cour reçoit un courrier elle
en accuse réception près de celui qui
l'attend voyez quelle que soit la
personne et quel que soit le sujet le
courrier du procureur est d'ailleurs
très clair il indique que le document en
question n'est qu'un accusé de réception
de la plainte et qu'il ne signifie pas
qu'une enquête sera prochainement
ouverte enquête hautement improbable